on the third of July armored personnel
carriers of the 1st Infantry Division
prepare to move northward in Vinh long
province as operation el paso continues
from a point 96 kilometers north of
Saigon the APC is head for a rendezvous
with division troops well forward of the
divisions field headquarters at quan LOI
after several hours the apc's arrived at
the designated rendezvous point and
secure the area the night will be spent
here and the troops are expected to meet
the armored unit in the morning soon a
resupply chopper appears with rations
water and mail for the crews of attract
vehicles for over a month since the
second of june men of the 1st division
have been engaged in operation el paso
in this area during that period Viet
Cong losses have been reported at 788
killed and 37 captured for the men of
the armoured elements a hot meal is
welcome mail call rounds out the day's
schedule then the APC crews settle in
for the night the following morning the
fourth of July a race is held by the
armored vehicle cruise while waiting for
the infantrymen to show up a strange
celebration of a holiday in the interior
of Vietnam
by the process of elimination heats only
three apcs are competing in the final
dash Charlie Chan is the winner's name
then it's time to pick up the troops for
the long ride back to Kwan loi the
tracks moved to meet the troopers as
they come out of the jungles the
rendezvous is made and the foot soldiers
board the vehicles after a long sweep
they look forward to riding when all of
the infantrymen are loaded aboard the
apc's form a long column and move
southward down jungle roads and across
brushy fields alert Gunners keep an eye
peeled for the enemy as they pass
through DC infested countryside armored
vehicles have been ambushed in the past
a Viet Cong suspect is spotted in the
brush and the convoy halts while he is
taken into custody in question the man
is by himself however and the column
continues on its way toward field
headquarters at quan loi
approaching the division area the column
is greeted by a welcoming banner later
in camp the APC crews here a letter of
commendation for their performance and
operation El Paso during June
at keaney on over 400 kilometers
northeast of saigon is the busiest US
Army Airfield in Vietnam a fixed
installation provides 24-hour a day air
traffic control personnel direct air
traffic operating under visual flight
rules direct ground control approaches
and login bound and outbound flights
Vietnamese civilians are being trained
here in various aspects of air traffic
flight control farther to the north west
at docto is another army airfield though
planned as a temporary field it has
hard-surfaced landing strips for
all-weather use air traffic control is
provided using a portable combination
flight control tower and radar van this
facility can be airlifted to other sites
to control flights during field
operations aircraft can land here during
inclement weather with the aid of a
ground control approach radar system
near play me 80 kilometers to the south
is the helicopter field for operation
Waikiki this airfield provides control
for helicopters supporting the 3rd
Brigade 25th Infantry Division when an
air transportable control van is not
available an air controller can direct
traffic effectively by using backpack
radio equipment
at Kenan Bey in Vietnam July 4th is no
holiday for the men of this engineer
port construction company the unit is
building a cross way between the shore
and it along pier these men are
assembling the 22,000 pound diesel
hammer which will be used to drive
piling into place here the hammer is
being set inside its guide frame which
is called the lead when the hammer is
operational it is positioned over the
pile to be driven a coffer dam is being
constructed and sheet piling is being
used this piling has been set in a
crossbeam to hold it in position as the
giant diesel hammer drives it into the
harbor floor when completed the
structure will be 46 feet in length and
the space between the retaining walls
will be filled with hydraulic balance
this is the second pair of this type to
be built by this engineer company
at anche a small crew of men is busy
blowing up balloons it's all part of the
activities of the camp Red Cliff
meteorological section military weather
men of the 1st air cavalry division
hydrogen gas is used to fill the big
weather balloons which are sent aloft
with data gathering instruments the
highly buoyant gas is manufactured right
on the spot helium which is preferred is
unavailable here as the time for release
nears the weather instrumentation
package is attached to the balloon then
the balloon soars upward with its
lightweight radiosonde to send back
information on wind speed and direction
a radio direction finder is used to
track the balloon and receive the
information from a law in turn the rdf
sends the data along to a nearby weather
van the mobile meteorology center during
this mission plots wind factors which
would affect the accuracy of long-range
artillery fire in the area the artillery
units need the information for fire
control computation as the information
is received it is recorded and quickly
analyze a report is then made to the
fire Direction Center where the fire
control team uses the data to compute
the adjustments required to place the
projectile on target the 8-inch
howitzers fire accurately and
successfully complete their mission
Vietnamese boys are enjoying the thrills
of scouting under the sponsorship of
American troop units stationed near
anche a boy scout troop and a Cub Scout
Pack organized through the efforts of
the local civil affairs unit here take
part in an overnight campout an
ornamental gate is erected by the scouts
tents for administration and sleeping or
set up as the area is made ready then
the ceremonies begin new Scouts after
they subscribe to the Scout Oath or
presented with troop neckerchiefs scout
berets and insignia
a group of shoeshine boys has been
invited to participate in the camp out
with the scouts these boys who help
support their families experience their
first camp out scouting means having fun
along with the camp chores and
ceremonies
the river bah then serves as the old
swimmin hole boys learn to swim and at
the same time practice one point of the
scouts law a scout is clean a project
which the Scout Troop has undertaken is
the restoration of a monument dedicated
to those people who have fled from North
Vietnam and join the fighting forces of
the Republic of Vietnam
American advisors and Vietnamese Scout
leaders work together to make this youth
program a success
on 29 jun in vietnam ceremonies marked
the departure of Sergeant Major William
O wooldridge for Washington to assume
his new duties as sergeant major of the
army later at fond salute wooldridge is
congratulated on his new assignment by
officers and men with whom he has served
most recently in the 1st Infantry
Division he is also presented with a
plaque as a memento of his service in
Vietnam with a big red one in his newly
created post sergeant major of the army
wooldridge will advise and consult with
the department of the army headquarters
on problems affecting enlisted personnel
training pay promotions and morale he
will also represent all enlistees and
appropriate ceremonies
it is evening in arnhem Holland and
crowds are gathering to watch the NATO
tap toe or tattoo representing the royal
family of the Netherlands Princess
Beatrix and her husband Prince Klaus
arrived to witness the colourful
ceremony in which military bands of the
NATO member countries will participate
this performance taking place on 27 jun
opens with a motorcycle parade at its
conclusion the combined bands appear
you
later in the performance this mast band
represents the United States
the Queen's Own Highlanders and the
Royal Scots greys join in this
presentation
finally all of the NATO bands joined to
conclude the program
you